welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
you've enjoyed his work in such films as
freedom and also rogue one and he is
back in season two of narcos Mexico and
is fantastic in it it is available for
streaming on Netflix starting next
Thursday he is Diego Luna good to see
you sir
thanks for coming here how are you I'm
very good I'm really happy did you say
that the conan the other night is there
I was freaking out here I'm very relaxed
okay it's not good yeah very nice I mean
everyone's so quiet chill atmosphere
it's also something we slipped into your
coffee we do to all our guests good to
see you here I'm a fan of your show man
it's really intense it's dark it gets
darker gets deeper your character gets
deeper and it is gonna be available for
streaming coming up next Thursday what
do you and I mean we just kind of hit it
a little bit with the TV audience about
how you have to really you must really
go to a dark place yeah father of the
cartel right now that's mm-hmm it is it
is a it is a show that is very demanding
and challenging for everyone also
because we are traveling all around
Mexico trying to portray the story where
it happened right and and yeah Mexico it
becomes a character of the show right
and and and then the scenes the scenes
are hardcore I mean this guy is always
like you know making it's he created
such a monster that now keeping it
together and and and surviving is not
easy and and it's been two years you
know and I have kids so I go back home
and I cannot talk about what I'm doing
they can't watch it so at the you know
for them is like
I have a double life you know sure don't
really know who their father is
my kids are 11 and 9 okay so then rogue
one was right up there right there yeah
yeah yeah okay then I mean I don't know
if I don't want to spoil it I'm if he
didn't watch it it's too late Wow look
it's like it was great for my son to
watch it read then obviously towards the
end we all decide you were my hero for
an hour and 15 you're not part of this
anymore so that's when you sit down and
you tell your children about a prequel
excited okay there's the Star Wars goes
all over the place I mean this is a now
it's happening now it's happening right
exactly so yeah I'm gonna go back to to
be the best dad ever
well sure Diego Luna here on the Rich
Eisen show what was that like to be
injected into the Star Wars franchise
for a film what was that like for you
that was spectacular I have to say
because it connected me with my
childhood with myself as audience you
know I started loving cinema because of
those films no kidding you know yeah
yeah yeah and I remember we had to wait
longer to watch them you know the new
guys here so a they would get like two
or three months later to Mexico sure and
it was it was a different time you know
like you you you would wait for a film
months and months and yeah I remember
signing for the toys you know like yeah
in the in the in the store in the toy
store you would be like yeah I wonder
Darva either and I want these and that
right and they would call you
you know once they got it so it was a
whole thing to be a fan you know it was
it's a name I mean yeah it was in every
day job
I think I'm older than you so I remember
my parents taking me into New York City
hmm to go to the famed Ziegfeld Theatre
to see the first Star Wars Wow
and I remember there was a ticket
holders line for the first time in my
young life
so you know you had to go online to buy
the ticket yeah and then you had to wait
on the line because you were holding it
to get in to the theater and first-come
first-serve for the seating and it was I
just remember I was like seven eight
years old and I'm so thrilled that my
parents realized the time what a
significant movie event this was
apparently gonna be yeah I was blown
away by it just absolutely blown away by
it so it was kind of neat to see rogue
one the way that they put it together as
a lead-up to try and set the table for
the movies that I grew up yeah it is how
much to do that genesis of Star Wars
right
we showed we showed a lot like emulating
how they did it back then I mean like we
constructed everything there's no green
screens you know the stuff is theater
yeah you push a button and things happen
in the cockpit then like they're the
things are there the the there's an
actor behind a mask and someone
operating the mask and it's all
mechanical like we were interacting with
real stuff now the lightsabers are I
mean yeah it was like what are you gonna
do in February and yes you would be like
I'm gonna watch Star Wars that's my plan
right because you have to do a lot sure
you know now with narcos for example it
comes out on the 13th I remember with
the first season people writing about
how much they liked the whole season
just the morning after it came up yeah
they were they've watched it through the
whole night 10 hours you know no sleep
and in the morning I love it now I gotta
wait a year I know exactly because
that's the Diego Luna here on the Rich
Eisen show I mean that's the whole thing
about streaming a show is that you know
you watch ones like I know and and my
wife and I when we watch a show that we
like so much you know we have three kids
and we kind of look at each other like
do we do another one like to be watching
the one is it's like kicking down at the
bottom of the screen 5 4 3 and it just
starts itself like okay that's it
going and it's just when you binge
something and obviously narcos Mexico is
so bin jabal that it can be do you can
kind of like I wouldn't know recommend
doing it all in one sitting
I'd be pretty dark to do anything that
takes ten hours of your life but uh but
I mean yeah it's like the fans of the
show are everywhere also you know right
I realized how many people watch the
show after after I did it you know
suddenly I didn't know it was so big I
guess
I love the the the the first season of
Escobar and and I had many friends
acting on that one
hmm and I watched it and I went like
well this is this is a good show but I I
didn't know it was so big we traveled
with the with the first season and we
went to Singapore we went to Mumbai we
went to Spain with and everywhere
there's huge fans of the show so I
really like I really like the
opportunity also to have so much talent
from Mexico in the show showing what
they're capable of in in something this
popular you know Diego Luna here on the
Rich Eisen show now then we were talking
in the green room about two of the most
fabulous Mexican footballers being right
here right
it's insane this was Mexico you know you
took the land and now you're taking a
strike you know it's not you know and
I'm sure they're really happy I'm sure
they're really happy yeah GG Reno here
in for the LA Galaxy right Chicharito
and you have Bella well they lie in in
the Emmy LA of six right
yeah and that's Will Ferrell's team so I
guess if you want to blame anybody you
blame I will talk to will yeah now you
were in which film were you in with well
Cassady my father haven't comedy I mean
I just love when I think
he plays a it's a it's all done like in
telenovela stylist and he he plays
everything in Spanish and how was that
for him horrible like like suddenly we
were improvising and you couldn't
improvise because he didn't know what to
say but it's so funny so funny the way
he delivers the lines is amazing did you
crack up because he was delivering it in
a certain words I mean the beauty of
working on a film like that is this
you're allowed to - yeah - laughs in the
middle of a take go back and start again
and yeah and everyone is laughing around
you and the camera guy you know like
it's it's it's funny kind of the
opposite of narcos Mexico invited you to
an LA FC game isn't what's going on I
don't know I think I'm gonna support you
Chet Ito because the this scene in the
that they built this beautiful Stadium
right next to the LA Coliseum downtown
the scene for an LA FC game is off the
charts really yes it is it's it it I
shouldn't say this cuz I haven't been to
one obviously
internationally but you could see it on
the screen right here I mean it it's
it's the real deal it looks like the
real deal you know uh-huh and you know
there's a shirtless guy right there
dancing around it's not probably nothing
you've ever seen before
yes it is and this was well this was the
Western Conference semifinal for the MLS
look at will there's will going around
there yeah they're fans of football
didn't care about it
when you see you guys I mean I guess
you're talking about Americans as a
whole talking about Americans ya know
the ml MLS there are some I know I know
these nine I'm know you're having fun
but ya know I like the MLS I I really
like the players finally you're bringing
players in their prime yes because you
know it was it was a retirement place
you know a retirement home like but now
now I mean Chicharito is coming at
thirty-one he still has a lot to give it
well this lot I'm just left you know I
mean on the very end of his string
although nobody would tell him that no
no and he's different
I mean yeah that's you could say 39 it's
better than many at 25 right still who
is the best footballer University who's
the best player you ever seen with your
own two eyes
yeah I would say Messi Messi of course
Messi I got to see I got to see Maradona
but I think Messi I love seed and see
then was amazing yes yeah yes I'm
fortunate the way his career ended
obviously but I mean I know I forgot
about that fast I mean you see you see
what he did in Real Madrid and I hate
Real Madrid right I'm a Barcelona fan
but what he did there it was spectacular
right so when you said you saw Maradona
where did you see him on the Blake
playing yeah just smiling because I just
you know where do we see him he was
flipping birds and stuff like that we
remember that he was given the finger to
somebody and screaming and yelling oh
yeah he's in the stands I'm talking yeah
yeah he's kind of crazy
he's definitely but he was he was
different
yeah yeah that's a player you know
definitely was different
there's no doubt about that Messi and I
share a birthday
other than a tree
we have nothing in common Messi is on
another level he plays a different sport
right now Will Ferrell yeah he he loves
his soccer I'll say it that way he loves
it
to the point where I am in a youth leave
my kids are in a Youth League okay in an
AYSO league here in town uh-huh and I
turn to my right during one of their
playoff games okay and who's working the
side with the flag like as an alt is a
side judge Will Farrell no way fact true
story and he came on this show what he
came on the show what about about a year
ago yeah right to promote Watson Watson
holmes with john c reilly yep and he
wore his entire he wore his he wore his
a YSL good with the shorts and
everything right there short short Nancy
what do you think of his moves right
here yeah well yeah so Wow yeah I
figured I'd bring that up while you're
sitting here he really is he's into it
he's totally into it and he did a good
job I mean he let everybody know like
when it was out and who's who's bad I'm
glad he's coming popular it's because we
are in the same Confederation yes and
it's it's kind of sad to play against a
team no one is following you no right
because we're talking about rival sure
you know it's a big rival then and and
and you want I mean we when you guys
come to a list of your stake which is
huge it's very it's it's I don't know
it's powerful and when they come to play
here many times there's more Mexicans
watching the games there's no question
about it
which which doesn't do good for for the
competition right right well
it's been fun having you on this show
Congrats on narcos Mexico thank you very
much very very much so and again season
two the anticipated season to start
streaming next Thursday February 13th on
Netflix come back any time at at Diego
Luna underscore on both Twitter and
Instagram this man has quite the
following on social media as well
appreciate you coming on sir thank you
for having you and let's do any time I
would love that Diego Luna here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app